DOWN INSIDE TURKISH AIRSPACE.
>> Reporter: TURKEY SAYS IT
WARNED THE RUSSIAN JET TEN TIMES
IT WAS VIOLATING TURKISH
AIRSPACE BEFORE ORDERING ITS
F-16s TO SHOOT DOWN THE RUSSIAN
AIRCRAFT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA PUTTING HIS FULL
SUPPORT BEHIND THE NATO ALLY.
>> TURKEY, LIKE EVERY COUNTRY,
HAS A RIGHT TO DEFEND ITS
TERRITORY AND ITS AIRSPACE.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. CALCULATES
THE RUSSIANS MAY HAVE BEEN
INSIDE TURKEY FOR LESS THAN 30
SECONDS.
LESS CLEAR IS EXACTLY WHERE THE
BORDER MAY BE.
>> IT HAPPENED, YOU KNOW, AT THE
BORDER, THAT MUCH I CAN TELL
YOU.
BUT BEYOND THAT, WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO COLLECT AND SIFT
THROUGH ALL OF THE DATA.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIAN PLANE
TOOK OFF FROM THE SYRIAN
AIRFIELD, HEADING NORTH.
THE U.S. MONITORING THE ENTIRE
TIME, USING RADARS AND RADIOS.
>> WE WERE ABLE TO HEAR
EVERYTHING GOING ON, THESE ARE
ON OPEN CHANNELS.
>> Reporter: AS THE PLANE WENT
DOWN, VIDEO POSTED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA SHOWS TURKISH-SUPPORTED
REBELS SHOOTING AT THE TWO
RUSSIAN PILOTS.
HEAVY FIRE FROM THE GROUND,
REBELS CALLING FOR THE PILOT'S
CAPTURE.
RUSSIAN HELICOPTER SEARCHING FOR
THE SECOND PILOT ALSO APPARENTLY
UNDER ATTACK, AND CRASHING.
A RUSSIAN MARINE KILLED ON THE
FAILED RESCUE MISSION.
CNN COULD NOT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THE VIDEO.
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
CALLED THE SHOOTDOWN A STAB IN
THE BACK.
>> Translator: IN ANY CASE,
NEITHER OUR PILOTS NOR OUR JET
POSED ANY THREAT TO THE TURKISH
REPUBLIC.
>> Reporter: PUTIN SAYS HIS
PLANES WERE TARGETING ISIS.
BUT THE U.S. SAYS THE RUSSIANS
ONLY STARTED FLYING IN THIS AREA
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS, AND WERE
TARGETING REBELS THAT TURKEY
SUPPORTS.
TURKEY DEFENDING ITS ACTIONS.
>> Translator: EVERYONE SHOULD
KNOW TURKEY HAS RIGHT TO
RESPONSE IF ITS AIRSPACE IS
VIOLATED DESPITE REPEATED
WARNINGS.
>> Reporter: THE QUESTION NOW,
IS PUTIN REALLY ANGRY OR DOES HE
HAVE A MORE IMMEDIATE GOAL?
>> HE BELIEVES THAT, IF HE
MAINTAINS HIS COOL, THAT
COUNTRIES LIKE FRANCE, GREAT
BRITAIN, AND HE HOPES ALSO THE
UNITED STATES, WILL ALLOW HIM AT
THE BIG TABLE AND THAT HE WILL
THEN GET A